okay so yeah i was asked what my general
approach to modern dating is
uh and i came up with this kind of this
general infrastructure it's generally
how it goes all right
so obviously the modern woman
is generally a narcissist generally like
they're generally addicted to energy
attention and so the first step is to
take no one gas like this woman right so
you ignore her because it shows your
high value
and you gasp like her by by kind of
alternating between the alpha she wants
and the beta feminism tells us she wants
right so you've got to be a badass but
also emotional and kind of vulnerable
but also ignore this woman or she will
lose interest
in other words show desperation and then
completely locked
it's a bunch of things but generally if
you fail at stimulating the modern
woman's limited attention span you lose
so you have to kind of flip between the
alpha
because they want they all want the top
guy but they want that top guy to need
them that's better [ __ ] so
so you know if i was if i was a six foot
three athlete with a six-footer job why
the [ __ ] would i want you like are you
that special you're not but i have to
convince you you are right
why do you have to convince us that we
are because
[ __ ] has infinite value right you don't
chase i chase you because you're a queen
you know that anyway so alpha beta
you gaslight right
um
you have to do at least these two and
flip between alpha and beta step two you
get the contact details right so the
female has been uh properly stimulated
you're like uh you know just get your
number instagram you talk to you
whatever
you have to keep this up this that one
never goes away constantly
you got to do that when you're married
you've got to go to your freaking coffin
doing that right am i going to die who
knows
that's sexy
watch any movie the guy is like i might
pass away any time now he's leaving
notes and [ __ ] this dude just doesn't
want to die he's just [ __ ]
gaslighting her right so step two you
get the contacts and you emotionally
babysit so because of the limited
attention
she has she has these knees right so by
emotionally babysit i mean you've got to
kind of help her grow emotionally she's
probably hurt by some loser um and
you're going to be one of those guys but
for now you've got to kind of sell or
trauma unpack all that stuff ask all
these cheesy questions no one really
cares about what was your last
relationship like do you value love uh
what kind of girl are you what kind of
guys she doesn't care what you liking it
so
a lot of you guys in this stage [ __ ] up
because you're telling her stuff about
you she doesn't care i've never heard a
woman be like i met this guy and he's
really interested in architecture she
doesn't care about that she doesn't care
all she heard was your job title and she
saw how you looked in your general
physique
that's it listen bro you drive exactly
so you mostly babysit this period takes
one to three weeks because obviously you
know you can't answer too frequently
you've got to give a time you know the
gas lighting and the ignoring is
important you've got to make her feel
like you might ignore the text
never reach too far you know make
statements don't ask questions or too
many questions and if you do ask a
question make sure it's something she
obviously wants to talk about like how
sexy she is her value in a long-term
relationship all that kind of [ __ ] that
actually doesn't mean anything but she
probably tells herself that every night
so
you do that one to three weeks has
passed now you're going for the kill
right
invite her on maximum few days this is
my role you guys you simps can do 100 if
you want but
i do three dates
date one
called close because you're still
gaslighting this [ __ ] right how could
you let her know you kind of want a
shagger don't don't let her know that
don't give her that power she's gonna
get gas so you guys like her you know
you're still kind of flipping between
alpha beta
second day you got to close because you
know we all got jobs and stuff you got
we got stuff to do right so we try and
close
if that fails you go back to step one
and repeat
if that
succeeds got this [ __ ] right so now
what you do is it lasts for about four
weeks you know now you're kind of just
you know texting and hooking up
generally
but you've got to tease a long-term
relationship at some point because you
know she's going to convince herself if
you've made it this far she probably
could see herself with you right but
obviously i'm just here to shack so i'm
just trying to you know i'm trying to
keep it going as long as possible so it
lasts about four weeks and then she's
kind of
okay i've noticed this kind of lines it
links up with the menstrual cycle the
next marshall cycle she's gonna be like
do i need this guy man you know of
everything generally so
after about a month things are going to
get shaky you tease long-term
relationship oh you know
what do you want i'm not sure yet i know
what i [ __ ] want i want a shag i
wanted a shack this whole time in a
month i'm going to want a shag it
doesn't change
but you tease that yeah and you don't
have to do it too hard don't try too
hard just say stay less less is more
right because then she'll just you know
she'll
figure out herself you know she'll think
what she wants to think and then you
repeat but generally you know everyone
has a shelf life she normally kind of
the smarter ones tend to kind of fade
away quicker
um but some of the smart ones last
longer those are the best but um
step fours you guys so when you end a
relationship with the modern woman
because the narcissist you really don't
want to give her any ammunition because
she will [ __ ] about you to everyone so
what you've got to do is you just go
call turkey you just stop if you explain
what she will tell people is the things
you just told her explained which is
going to be [ __ ] because we all just
want to [ __ ] so she's going to tell
other people that and then there's going
to be rumors and there's going to be all
this energy i don't want to give you
that ammunition so
i'll just ghost you yeah i'll just like
just
that's why why explain anything is she
going to listen to you or not like i get
that i wouldn't be with me either she's
not so what's the point is she gonna
take your critique absolutely not she's
probably a modern woman she probably
thinks she can do it too
she's probably gonna tell you that like
you're some [ __ ] you were abusive or
manipulative or
some kind of dash like i would kind of
wear gas lighting but listen we have to
do it it's modern times
um so that's generally the
infrastructure um it's a lot more
complicated than this class any
questions uh um i i have a question yeah
i have one too i have a question first
date right first date
right do you take us somewhere fancy
would you keep it cheap
[Music]
listen
this is a system right
and every system has limitations
in this case it's just time which is
obviously everyone's limitation but
there's also money b in fact i'm doing
this for four or five [ __ ] at the
same time do you think i made the money
that's what i'm saying do you think i'm
gonna take you out to top restaurants
thank you with no guaranteed sucks are
you dumb okay
are you
stupid you think you're that special
so you'd agree that if you spend these
resources and time and energy then she
should be giving you success you know
what i mean nothing is guaranteed
nothing is guaranteed in life which is
why we go
but do you believe
listen it doesn't matter what i believe
i live i live by reality so this is this
is
you're like listen i'm doing five so at
least one may fall through you want to
give it out
it's kind of like job applications right
fire them out do you make one job
application and get all hyped up in your
little chair
you make ten job applications you get
three interviews and then maybe you get
one job offer that's fine but the key
thing is the limitation the key
limitation of this is money and time and
so the time restriction is seen here
right three days that's my general rule
because i've got a good job i've got all
this stuff going other [ __ ] you know
stuff like that and the other key
limitation is money so you know
i push it like trading in it you don't
want to invest more than you're willing
to lose yeah i'm not willing to lose
more than 25 pounds on anything right
listen you get the first drink i get the
first drink it's like oh you know i'm
being a gentleman if you don't get this
second drink you're not getting anything
else right i mean this has to alternate
this has to occur i will i'll give it to
you though i won't even leave i'll just
be like you get in the next round and if
she doesn't i'll be like this [ __ ] i
won't even keep it for four weeks if i
struggle with i'll probably be two weeks
right um so yeah that's that's the main
about this
any any other any other questions class
can i ask a question
what type of women do you attract with
this what type of women do you manage to
trap in this cycle um actually
i wouldn't say trap i think they come of
their own accord but
generally
my my main demographics are early 20s
university student highly intelligent
intelligence is my key factor i can't do
dumb girls so in other words
done women are too chaotic for me and
it's just it doesn't fit my lifestyle
right don't do any dumb hoes up in here
so they all got to kind of know you know
what color this guy is that kind of
thing
early 20s and their university graduates
they've gone to good uni's and they just
want to mess around and she knows what
she wants i don't have time to waste so
if you're kind of just figuring out you
can do that on someone else's time i've
got stuff to do the other demographic is
mid-30s and they've kind of been around
maybe has some [ __ ] relationships they
you know almost got married whatever and
now they're just chilling these probably
they're easier to maintain as well
because you know they're 30 you know has
to manage themselves young girls want a
lot of your time and attention the older
women are my favorite because at this
this current time they're just as
attractive as 22 years but they're more
like independent they can manage
themselves less stressful they'll even
take you out did i have kids facts um
so yeah generally is those two
occasionally i will trap a mid-twenties
girl in her peak
but obviously it's because you know i
know it's not what's best for her and i
i avoid doing that i like i like to mess
with women who
uh we can have fun and it doesn't have
any judgement on a long-term
relationship prospects you're
considerate
i am
i treat every woman like that's
someone's potential wife in it so i
wouldn't do anything with them that like
would make any other guy i have a good
reputation right that's because i work
very hard but you know this crazed
trauma right i'm just gonna say like the
younger ones that it does create trauma
you know it's like a cycle of
psychological issues being a modern
woman creates trauma you already have
trauma that's why you like this stage no
but relationship trauma when it starts
in the get-go a woman gets hurt by a man
a man gets hurt by a woman next you know
everyone's just out here just trying to
be savage mode okay like the worst thing
about that let's think about that okay
yeah i'll think about it and here's
here's my output right go ahead no one
hurt you i ghosted you no one did [ __ ]
you see yeah i fell in love that's her
business b that was you you you charmed
her come on because i'm a champion
exactly some credit for that though yeah
but let's take some credit your feelings
belong to you i can't affect how you
yeah just because i'm awesome
she didn't
like you can fall in love you can do
whatever you want
you've got four week cycles right that's
that's how it is have you been in love
um
as many of you know i was just banned on
tick tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible